revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez más conmigo en el
estudio rosa abrimos esta revista de
prensa con el asesinato de la periodista
es decir asir en abu dhabi le
presuntamente por el ejército israelí
esta muerte entonces abre las portadas
internacionales del día de hoy jueves
que se celebra su funeral en ramala
exactamente buenos días raúl como ayer
veíamos no que esta noticia pues estuvo
presente en muchísimos medios de
comunicación alrededor del mundo hoy no
son tantos los que destacan o hacen un
seguimiento a este asesinato en su
portada particularmente de raúl para
volver un poco a lo que comentábamos
ayer fue muy criticado el titular de la
new york times' que en un primer momento
dijo que la periodista irina buckler
murió a los 51 años como quien muere de
un infarto o de una enfermedad o de
muerte natural y también lo de que murió
en medio de enfrentamientos algo que
desmintieron los distintos testigos pero
vamos al 'washington post' a este medio
estadounidense que hoy titula en su
portada las tropas israelís disparan una
reportera estadounidense
la cadena y es que recordemos que la
periodista de al yazira tenía también
ciudadanía estadounidense además de
palestino por otro lado o globo de
brasil dice el asesinato de una
periodista genera conmoción en oriente
medio y es que recordemos no que era una
un gran rostro de la cadena de al yazira
para el mundo árabe y en las fotos en la
foto principal vemos ya es su cuerpo
cubierto con flores y la bandera
palestina por las calles de ramala en
cisjordania y también vemos la imagen de
ella aquí más a la izquierda
y dice que este medio que fue una de las
primeras corresponsales de guerra y
árabes recordemos que empezó en 1997 en
la cadena catarí y también pues que no
sólo cubrió grandes momentos bélicos
sino también la cotidianidad del pueblo
palestino bajo un régimen que
organizaciones como human right watch
han calificado de apartheid vamos ahora
al jerusalem post' que es un medio más
bien de derechas y sionista de israel
que titula ya de una forma muy distinta
dice las fuerzas de defensa israelíes el
ejército de israel investiga en la
muerte de la periodista de al yazira más
tarde entraremos en esta investigación
porque también ha levantado polémica y
sí es verdad que señala que en medio de
enfrentamientos algo que como decíamos
los testigos pues arrebaten y cita a
eeuu que dijo que el asesinato de la
reportera de al yazira es un ataque a la
libertad de prensa y también destaca que
ella era la voz y el rostro de palestina
para todo el mundo árabe vamos a la
prensa francesa porque liberación que
realmente dedica la portada pues sólo a
un tema en este caso tiene unos breves
en la parte inferior de la portada y
destaca palestina muerte de la
periodista es irina buckler israel
señalado esta muerte no pues lo que
decíamos el peso de las palabras y estos
equilibrios que se hacen en estos casos
y más cuando estos hechos tienen lugar
en territorios palestinos y vamos a
mediapart a que si dices irina buckler
el rostro sin miedo del periodismo
palestino rosa y como lógica elegir en
la cadena donde a clay que trabajaba
desde hace 25 años como lo estábamos
comentando efectivamente pues al yazira
como comprenderá se está haciendo una
seguimiento en portada de del tema y
precisamente estaba retransmitiendo en
vivo esta ceremonia en ramala en el
complejo presidencial de la autoridad
nacional palestina donde mahmud abás
dijo que iremos a la corte penal
internacional no confiamos en ellos en
el sentido de que no confía en que
israel pues se lleve a cabo una
investigación digamos honesta sobre este
asesinato y precisamente destacamos que
al yazira en el rótulo con el que
identificaba esta ceremonia podía
ceremonia de estado y pues esto señalar
que el funeral como tal el enter el
entierro perdón tendrá lugar mañana en
jerusalén rosa y cuáles han sido
entonces las reacciones de parte de eeuu
bien pues han sido diversas no pero por
como decíamos la periodista a voeckler
ella tenía ciudadanía estadounidense
pero finalmente el departamento de
estado de eeuu dijo que confiaba en
israel para investigar el caso a lo que
aguas knight director de la campaña de
derechos palestinos de eeuu citado en al
yazira dijo no puedes esperar que los
israelís se investiguen a sí mismos
cuando llevan violando los derechos
humanos 70 años y que lleguen a una
conclusión distinta a la que llegan
desde hace décadas dijo la comunidad
internacional ha sido testigo de
atrocidades una y otra vez e israel
nunca ha rendido cuentas y esto es
difícil que cambie esta rendición de
cuentas no mientras israel siga siendo
uno de los principales aliados de eeuu y
de occidente en la región y al yazira da
el siguiente dato dice que este año
washington sumó mil millones de dólares
a su asistencia militar anual de 3 mil
800 millones de dólares a israel en este
caso este aumento estaría justificado
para reforzar el sistema antimisiles
cúpula de hierro y también a destacar
que la congresista de eeuu realidad life
también de raíces palestinas dijo ayer
no podemos permitir que los mismos que
cometan estos crímenes hagan la
investigación dijo surín agua clair
estaba ahí defendiendo la verdad y
haciendo su trabajo y fue asesinada por
un gobierno de apartheid que continuamos
financiando con ayuda incondicional rosa
vamos ahora con el país de españa porque
publicó una entrevista con la líder del
grupo pong ruso pussy radio está además
obviamente famoso por ser opositor al
kremlin exactamente nomás la conocida
líder de este grupo punk feminista
opositor a putin de rusia logró salir
del país tras varios intentos fallidos y
logró salir básicamente disfrazada de
repartidora no como se ve en esta imagen
que destaca el país ella explica que
responde a la periodista de el país
desde islandia pero desde una ubicación
no revelada por miedo a que la localicen
y responde por la aplicación a telegram
no así mantiene una conversación con
laura fernández dice que putin no le da
miedo a pesar de que pues tiene armas
muy peligrosas
lamenta que el feminismo no haya llegado
a rusia donde es tan sólo la palabra da
miedo al gobierno de vladímir putin y
por último está en islandia pero no
descarta de hecho quiere volver a rusia
para continuar luchando contra putin
desde dentro sin embargo ahora va a
empezar una gira por europa para
representar la versión teatral del libro
riot days que es un libro que ya
escribió hablando del maltrato el
maltrato de las mujeres en las prisiones
rusas algo que ella conoce bien porque
pues ha estado en relación en múltiples
ocasiones rosa como siempre gracias por
toda la información nos vemos mañana
viernes con más revista de prensa
pasamos a saludar a nuestro invitado el
día